-[Voiceover] Let's
think a little bit about
modeling population and
what I have pictures here
are some of the most known,
actually this gentleman right over here
might be the most known
person when people think about
population and the limits
to grow the population.
This is Thomas Malthus.
He was a British cleric
and writer and scholar
at the end of the 1700s, at
the end of the 18th century,
early 19th century.
He really challenged the notion
that population could grow indefinitely
and that we would always
through technology
be able to feed ourselves
and that really that the
environment would eventually
put some caps on how much
or where the population could grow to.
P.F. Verhulst and I'm sure
I'm mispronouncing his name here.
He was a Belgian mathematician
who read Malthus’ work
and tried to model the behavior
that Malthus was talking about
that, okay when there aren't
environmental constraints,
maybe population does grow
somewhat exponentially
but then as it approaches
kind of the limits
set by the environment
it's going to essentially asymptote
towards some type of population.
Malthus in particular,
he actually doesn't think
it's just going to be
a nice clean asymptote.
He actually thinks that the population
would kind of go above the limit
and you'd have these catastrophes
and then they would go
crashing below the limit
and you kind of oscillate
right around the limit
through these catastrophes.
You can tell Malthus was
a fairly optimistic guy
but let's go through a
little bit of the math
and a little bit of the
differential equations
although it's not too,
these aren't overly hairy
differential equations to
think about population.
The first way to think about population
and I'll express it as
a differential equation.
Actually let me just
set some variables here.
Let's say that N is our population,
so that's our population
and we are going to assume
that N is a function of T.
N as a function of T
is what we're going to
be thinking about in this
and frankly the next series of videos.
One way to think about how to model this
is just so what is the rate of change
of population with respect to time?
How does that relate to things?
We could say, okay, well
what is the rate of change
of population with respect to time?
D, capital N, DT.
Well one way to think about it
is it's going to be
proportional to the population.
You could say well maybe
this is going to be
some proportionality constant
times the population,
times the population itself.
This makes sense if the
population is smaller
then you're not going to have as much
change per unit time as if
the population is larger.
The larger the population the more
it's going to grow in a
particular unit of time.
Actually this is actually
a fairly simple to solve
differential equation, you
might have done it before.
I encourage you to pause this video
if you feel inspired to do so
but I'll solve it right here
and you'll see that we get
an exponential function here
for N, so let's do that.
Let's solve this and we'll essentially
separate the variables,
separate the N from the Ts
although we only see DT here
but I'll do that in a second.
If I divide both sides by N.
I get one over N and if I
multiply both sides by DT
if you kind of think about the DT
is something that you can multiply.
I'm going to multiply both sides
or I'm going to divide both sides by
and multiply both sides by DT.
I'm going to get one over N,
DN on the left-hand side
and on the right-hand
side I'm going to get
R times DT.
Notice I got the DT
onto the right-hand side
by multiplying both sides of that
and then I divided both sides by N
and I got the one over N right over here.
Now what we can do is we
can take the antiderivative
of both sides.
We can take the
antiderivative of both sides
and what do we get on the left-hand side?
Well this is just going
to be the natural log
of the absolute value of our population
and actually if we assume
that the population
is always going to be non-zero
then we can actually take
this absolute value off
but I'll do that in a second.
That's going to be equal to R times T
and then we could have
added the constant here
but I'm just going to do it on one side.
It's R times T plus C.
Now, if we actually want to solve for N,
we could take ...
If this is equal to this
then E to this power
should be the same as E to this power
or another way of thinking about it,
E, the natural log of
the absolute value of N
is equal to this.
Is another way of saying that E to this
is going to be equal to that.
Well actually let me just do it this way.
Let me just take E to this power
and to that power.
If that's equal to that
then E to that power
should be the same as E to that power.
We're going to be left
with E to the natural log
of the absolute value of N.
That's going to give you
the absolute value of N.
Let's just assume N positive,
let's just assume population
is greater than zero.
Then we can this left-hand
side right over here
we'll just simplify to N
and then our right-hand
side it's going to be ...
Well it could be E to the RT plus C
or this is the same thing.
This thing right over
here is the same thing
as E to the RT, E to the R times T, times,
actually let me do that
E in that same color.
E to the RT, times E to the C,
times E to the C, right?
I'm just taking E to the
sum of these two exponents.
That's going to be E to
the RT, times E to the C.
If we want to, we could
just hey you know what,
this is still just going to be some
arbitrary constant here.
Actually let's just call this C.
It's E to the RT times C
or we could say C times E to the RT.
Notice, so we have solved
the differential equation.
We haven't gotten to this kind of
less than optimistic reality of Malthus
where we're limiting it.
This is just hey, if we
just assume population
is going to ...
The rate of change of
population with respect to time
is going to be proportional to population.
When we solve that differential equation,
we get that population
is a function of time.
Actually let me make it explicit
that this is a function of time.
Let me just move the N over a little bit,
so let me write it this way.
N of T is going to be equal to this.
This was our solution to
this differential equation.
Once again this is going
to just grow forever
and if we know the initial conditions
and so let's say that
we knew that N of zero
when time is equal to zero.
Let's just say that's N sub naught
so what would C be?
Well N of zero is going to be equal to C.
C times E to the zero power.
You know the zero power is just one
so this is going to be equal to C,
so C is equal to N sub naught.
Now we can even write it
that the solution to this
thing right over here
is N as a function of T
is going to be equal to C times ...
Be careful, N naught,
our initial population,
times E to the E to the RT.
Now once again this is an exponential.
Essentially our population
is going to look like this.
If I were to graph it, it's going to look
if that's my time axis,
that's my N axis right over here.
I could say it's Y equals N axis,
however I want to denote it.
That would be N naught
and it's going to grow
exponentially from there.
The rate of this exponential function
is going to be dictated by
this constant right over there
but it's going to be
look something like this
and it's just going to grow
faster and faster and faster
forever and ever and ever and ever.
Now, as I mentioned at the
beginning of the video,
Malthus does not believe
that this is going to be true.
He thinks that we're going
to hit some natural limits
that are going to start to
constrain the population.
In his mind the more natural
or more realistic function
to model population
would look something like this
or even potentially something
that you keep going crashing
around that kind of limit.
What we'll see in the next
video is that P.F. Verhulst
actually came up with a very
good one differential equation
and solution to the differential equation
that does model a lot
better, that better describes
the reality that Malthus
believed that we were in.